hello
well first of all thank you Nevada thank
you
so grateful to every volunteer who
knocked on doors who made phone calls
who wrote postcards and letters and who
had the courage to publicly stand up and
fight for our state
Allison to all nevadans whether whether
you voted for me or not I will always
fight for you always
now
as Frank said we've we've known this was
going to be a tough campaign but
like all of you I'm in Nevada and I know
what it takes to deliver for my home
state so when the national pundits said
I couldn't win
I knew Nevada would prove them wrong
because in Nevada no one gets left
behind there's no one and that means
standing up for our families when no one
else will
as a former Attorney General I I never
ever wavered in my support for our law
enforcement and First Responders
including our firefighters they have the
toughest jobs in the state and they keep
our families safe so thank you for your
support in this race and I will always
have your back
and I am also standing with the people
who make this state run our workers our
essential labor
thank you
every day every day I am proud to call
the men and women an organized labor
family
[Music]
you have been a part of my life since I
was a child growing up the daughter of a
Teamster
yes you built this country you are the
essential workers on the front lines
every single day you've protected our
workers and their families here in
Nevada and I will always fight for you
no matter what because it is about our
families
thank you
as you all know
um I don't forget where I come from
I have a grandfather Who Came From
Chihuahua Mexico
for to this country for a better life
[Music]
grandmother from Las Cruces New Mexico
and they worked hard they worked hard
and my parents worked hard in this
community growing up here to support our
family
it is the story of so many Latino
families across our state it's the story
of so many Latino families across the
country right right
I know I know my family not only those
that are here
today but those that have passed would
be so proud to see me serving as the
first Latina in the U.S Senate
but even prouder to see me re-elected
oh
like all of you I've never forgotten
where I come from and where my Camp
family came from every single day I will
continue to fight for a Latino community
the far-right Republicans said they knew
better I knew we would prove them wrong
right and today we did the victory is
for Nevada and all of us all of the hard
work that we put into it this election
this election nevadans rejected the
far-right politicians working to divide
us
we rejected their conspiracies their
attacks on our workers and their efforts
to restrict our freedoms
six years ago when you elected me to the
U.S Senate I cast a deciding vote to
protect health care for millions of
Americans
we know
without nevadans the Affordable Care Act
would have been repealed
it was all of us working together and
I'm telling you I am ready for more
tough fights like that so when
Republicans try to force through a
federal abortion ban I'm going to stop
them
[Applause]
I have stood up for Nevada every day in
the U.S Senate and I'm not going to stop
anytime soon thanks to all of your hard
work we are going to not only continue
to fight for Nevada we're going to work
hard to bring down housing costs for
Nevada and so everyone everyone can
afford a roof over their head and a
place to call home
we are going to keep creating these good
paying union jobs right here in Nevada
and we are going to ensure that every
individual who works hard to provide for
themselves and their families or in
service to this country can retire with
dignity
and I will never
ever give up fighting for our immigrant
families
right that means that means a pathway to
citizenship for dreamers our TPS holders
our essential workers and our Farm
Workers these navads deserve to feel
safe here in their home and I will work
with anyone anyone to ensure they are
treated with dignity
now
I have a lot of people to think
including so many in this room from all
the organized labor everybody from the
red shirts right to so many others the
blue shirts to everybody that has been
out here standing behind me purple
shirts this
this is Nevada right here this is a
representation of who we are when we
fight for our Working Families and we
couldn't do it alone
because when we stand together we stand
strong and we can make a difference We
Know It And as an events I will never
forget it and always always have your
back thank you thank you now
there's also somebody I have to think
because he has been with me
from the very beginning and he has had a
a tough time because I I have to tell
you these races are hardest on the
family I have to thank my husband Paul
who has been by my side every step of
the way
and you know my family I talk about them
all the time I have to thank my mother
Joanna my sister Cynthia and all of my
Aunts Uncles tsdos cousins Primos nieces
nephews everybody that has been out
there fighting so hard and support
foreign
and then we would not have the success
we have today without the Strategic mind
of so many people but one person
in particular
who has been in this fight with me for
so long I have to thank Scott Fairchild
understood that this fight was all about
Nevada and he made sure we could win and
keep delivering for this state so Scott
thank you on behalf of Nevada and all
the hard work
and then also my Senate team the
official team the reason why we were
successful is because of the hard work
of so many people that are on my team
for the last six years that put nevadans
first that answered those calls that
answered those emails that talk to
people individually that fought for
nevadans and never fought forgot why we
are here in the first place it's to make
sure we are delivering on behalf of
every Nevada my Senate team they're
phenomenal and I thank you every single
day for what you do from Nevada
and then to our organizers who knocked
on doors made thousands of phone calls
thank you in a race this tithe it made
the difference it made a difference
and finally finally
I want to thank my entire campaign team
this was a team effort it's never about
one person it is about all of us working
together and I will tell you the
campaign team their passion their belief
in doing it for the right reasons and
being here and putting in those long
days and nights traveling all across
this state you never lost sight about
what it was for you made this happen so
thank you to the incredible men and
women on the campaign team who were
there for the last two years working so
hard for this state this is your success
thank you
and then I absolutely have to
acknowledge all of the Democrats running
up and down the ticket some of them are
here and some of them are out there
already getting ready uh working their
jobs nevadans are better off because of
the service of people like Governor
Steve sisselek who has always always
and I am looking forward to continuing
continuing to work with Dina Titus
Stephen horsehart and Susie Lee
and then thank you because of the hard
work of all of your everything that
we've put into this this election we
have incredible constitutional officers
that are going to stand and fight for us
and defend us we have a state house
that is democratically controlled that
will continue to fight for our rights
and make sure our freedoms are not
eroded and every single Democrat who put
their name on the ballot to defend our
communities thank you thank you thank
you thank you
so with that said like all of you I am a
proud nevadan every single day I do not
forget where I come from
and when I walk into that capital
I take all of you with me because this
is about all of us standing strong
together and making sure our voices are
heard I will always fight for Nevada and
for all of you and I cannot thank you
enough for all of the time commitment
effort everything that you put into this
election now
we celebrate and let's continue the work
thanks everyone
[Applause]
[Applause]